and so today I will talk more about the
connection between Dynamic algorithm and
the adversaries
um so
so what would you will see just as I
um say just briefly last time we will
see the different kind of adversaries
and then just show you the template so
far in the literature how do people
design algorithms against each of the
adversary
and this is just a to remind you that
really Dynamic algorithm
always interact with some guy right like
it can be a user
and
you also called user uh we also call the
user adversary because we think of like
this guy to like generate some some
worst case worst case sequence for us
but the sequence is not always the worst
case but yeah anyway we call it
adversary
and
um
there are two like a big uh if you want
to separate kinds of adversary that like
you can be five grand and make many
kinds of them but um the the two big
thing is the oblivious one and the
Adaptive One
so
the oblivious one is just the one that
basically fix the whole sequence of
update and queries
from the beginning you can think like
it's just fixed this sequence it has
some fixed sequence in mind but just
review each of the update in query to
you one by one at a time but this
sequence is fixed from the beginning
so this is oblivious in the sense that
it doesn't really like
see your answer it doesn't like the next
update doesn't depends on what you enter
it's oblivious to that
then another another adversary is just
the opposite of that that is
um we say it's adaptive that is this is
a guy that generate the the the the
update and query on the fly in the sense
that the next update
is generated based on previous answer
that it has seen so far
if your data structure returns something
then it might change you it is mine and
give you the next question depending on
what what you what you answered
so for example you can think like
um
maybe like
there are many people who use the Google
Maps right
um and maybe some some people want to go
from A to B then this Google Map might
say okay the path is to go through this
part p
and because so many people use use this
uh path then it will like it might be
the case that okay now the traffic on
path p in place just because just
because this uh this app say okay you
should go through part p
so this is what I mean by adaptive it's
like like the user might not be
adversarial but
um it just might be the case that okay
the next update just depends on the on
the answer uh naturally
um
and yeah so
adaptive adversary can happen naturally
and will be will happen really a lot in
in the
when you use the data structure
inside another static algorithm
so this is like a strong adversary that
you want to work with
usually
and just one term uh in this talk I will
use the word robust to just say that
um an algorithm works against adaptive
adversary so it doesn't assume that the
adversary is oblivious otherwise we say
it's non-robust
yes yes
what did they will use in this talk
Okay so so far you have seen like a
bunch of model of
data structure Dynamic data structure
now and so basically the ultimate goal
is to
design
fastest Dynamic algorithms that are
first it should be fully Dynamic also it
should be Rob
it should be robust instead of non-robus
and also it should have worst case
update time so usually like
in the in this area there are so many
variants of the model right but like you
can say you can think like Okay
um
the ice there is one goal one Holy Grail
that we are aiming for
um
it's a good scientific question like um
whether you can give corrector like what
is a to what extent you can go to this
ultimate goal uh can we give some
characterization when you can get fully
Dynamic when can when can you make it
robust and worst case at that time
um so inside the dynamic data structure
this is a goal this is a goal but
just want to
um
make it clear that
this ultimate goal is not always needed
if you don't care about Dynamic data
structure itself
um
many times we design Dynamic data
structure so that we want to get uh
faster static algorithm
and
all these three things
um are not always needed
so to to like uh give you an example
I want to
tell you one
simple example how
one can use Dynamic algorithm in size
static algorithm
and you see that like
um
the strongest model here that we need is
not always necessary that that'd be one
is not always necessary
okay so the example that I want to show
is like
it's one of the simplest algorithm for
completing my flow that
um I think
um
um if you haven't seen it then then I
think many people have seen it but if
you haven't seen it it it's quite simple
and cute so let's let's see what is this
algorithm for computing Max flow it is
based on a well-known framework called
multiplicative with update
okay
so what is this algorithm
so imagine that you have a problem where
you okay this is a Maxwell Problem you
want to send flow from s to T and let's
say every Edge has unit capacity for
just for Simplicity okay
so now what do we do first
you will just initialize the weight of
every Edge to be something small
and okay
what do you want to do is keep doing
something
as long as
the distance from stt is less than one
what you do is to you first compute some
shortest part from stt
can be even approximate one
let's call that thing p
and when you have the shortest path P
just kind of add this path into your
flow so flow you can think of of it as
like a collection of path right so add
this path into your flow
and what we do next is just increase
every Edge on the path by a factor of
one plus Epsilon
and repeat
so
you so note that there is no residual
graph at all you keep working on the
same graph
this like if the graph is undirected
this is the undirected graph at all time
okay
they keep fighting shortage path
increase the weight
and do this the
um again and again until the distance at
some point the distance will will be
more than one and at that point you stop
um
and um then
um then you just return the floor that
you have since of just the collection of
all path that you have seen so far
return that but you scaled out just
scale it down so that like um
um
it is like it respect the capacity but
once you scale it down so that this this
collection of path respect the capacity
then that is already uh approximate map
flow
so early
what's the definition he said capacity
he's doing unit capacity getting
adjusted
delayed in a different way yes yeah it
generalized nicely if you yeah um
if you have capacity in the initial
weight of each Edge will be like this
thing
okay one over this thing times capacity
so
if some Edge have flash capacity is
initial wave well
will be smaller
and okay and and there will be some some
some small adjustment in in how you
update but anyway this is for like this
full thing is for unit capacity graph
so
so you see that like okay
um this is some nice algorithm it's uh
simple analysis is not too too hard but
I will not actually tell you why this
gives you approximate next flow
um but at least we can see that
it is quite fast
why because you can see that the number
of iterations will be close to linear
linear in m
the reason is that
every Edge will be used something like
every Edge will be used in or in the
path add more something like log over
Epsilon Square actually Epsilon Square
Mini
many paths
uh and and the reason is just that every
time that you use some Edge is Edge
increase is the weight by one plus
Epsilon Factor right uh it this increase
like uh exponentially so after some
point
is where it will be more than one
and once it the weight is more than one
it would mean it never will be used in
the path of length less than one ever
so every Edge will be used at most um
like something like lock or Epsilon
Square Times
I missed the square but anyway
um
and because of that
each iteration you can charge it to some
Edge
so that would be like something like
linearly many many iterations each
iteration you need you can spend linear
time if you compute shortest parts from
scratch so that's M squared time
title
so that's quite nice but
just from the description of the
algorithm right
um it's quite clear that um
one should be able to improve this using
Dynamic data structure
like because we want to we should be
able to avoid Computing this shortage
path from scratch at every step
and what do we need from that well
um what we need is just a dynamic
shortest path problem
and the kind of problem that we need
is partially Dynamic it's partially
dynamic in the sense that the all this
update is monotone
it's always weight increase
it's not fully dynamic
also
you only care about a more ties update
time if it has good amortize at that
time this is fine because you just need
to count the total up that time uh from
this like single update sequence
from the algorithm
so here you see that you at least need
to need the algorithm to be robust
because
each of the update
really directly depends
on on your answer
generate adaptively
and indeed like because like from from
this thing like
there's like one of my previous work
really like implement this
robust one that is partially Dynamic and
have like into the little one amortized
at that time which leads to
um speed up of this running time from M
Square to almost linear so this this can
be this can indeed be be useful
um the dynamic data structure
um
can be used to speed up
multiplicative way to update framework
and it has been used in actually many
other examples
so
I just want to like kind of
tell you briefly that
um okay
it would be most of the time when when
you try to implement
um with update framework to solve some
problem
um
yeah the kind of
the kind of um Dynamic there's a
structure that you need is Rob you
usually needed to be robust partially
Dynamic and amortized like as amortized
up that time
but if you designed a algorithm based on
some other framework like interior Point
method
um
like it will generate different kind of
uh model of dynamic data structure that
you you will need for example usually
when you use internet Point method you
need fully dynamic
and there was some recent work based on
some other method and now it turns out
that this this framework
requires really exclusively
um need that the algorithm must have
worst case at that time
and yeah there are like various of
various of of of of method some method
you don't like there are some algorithm
from geometry and like something about
um
something about Electrical uh electrical
flow um but that's not the point of
point is that the algorithm
just make some list of queries that they
want to know none adaptively so now all
you need is just even offline algorithm
yeah
and so my point is just there are many
kinds of variants of optimization and
thought and each of them
um
like leaves two different requirements
of dynamic data structure
so
yeah you don't always need the dynamic
data structure in the strongest model to
get good applications
question
yes just quickly so in multiplicative
way it's update when you say it's only
partially Dynamic like you just mean
monotonous City or do you is there
something else I really need more at
Holy City when I asked repeat the
question around oh yes thanks um the
question is um when I say partially
Dynamic yeah uh do I mean like um is it
only
escalation or I just mean like the
update is monotone uh in some sense I I
just mean it's monotone but usually when
when the when the update is monotone you
can really stimulate that with like Edge
deletion only or incision only yeah
yeah okay
so yeah there are like
um the landscape of Designing
Dynamic data structure
together jointly with optimization
method I think it's worth exploring like
um it's not just like there is one
single goal that uh like it's a rich
area
okay
but yeah the rest of the talk
um at least for this talk I want to give
you at least some templates how people
design algorithms that exploit oblivious
adversary and how to decide the one that
is against adaptive adversary
yeah so let's start with the the
oblivious adversary one the non-robus
one
it would be two thing let's start with
the first one which I call a
idea is that random point is stable in
some sense
so let's see the concrete exam concrete
problem with a full proof
okay
so
this is a dynamic approximate diameter
problem
but
um
just for Simplicity of uh of
presentation I will actually not work on
graph I will work on Metric okay
so in this problem you have let's say
you think of you have a point set X
in the metric d
and you can think of it as like
euclidean space or something
and this point set underco that
undergoes uh insertion and deletion you
can remove points you can insert a point
and now the time complexity that I will
count is like how many times you need to
query the distance between two points
okay
what we want to do
is like a kind of decision version of
approximate diameter so
we want to return like a yes no answer
and we wanted if the diameter X which is
just defined to be the the maximum
distance between any pairs of points if
the diameter of your point set is less
than beta say some threshold then you
say yes
okay
and
if you return Yes the diameter should be
like less than two beta so in other
words if the diameter actually is much
more than beta more than two better you
should say no
just for example okay
here the diameter is like a three beta
so you return now
but now you I might delete this node
this this point now you should return
yes
and if I add
at this no this point
now diameter is like somewhere between
beta and two better so you can return
anything
so a trivial
algorithm right um
is to recompute everything from scratch
and that takes n Square was cast query
like just
the compute diameter by
querying every pairs
and what I will show you is you can
improve this to understand
at that time in expectation
so
let's see the algorithm
algorithm
is that it will at least let me first
state one invariant that is that is
important the algorithm will try to
maintain one point R and this R should
be random it should be a uniformly
random point in your set
and there is one subroutine that I call
Shake all that is it just returned yes
if
um the distance from R to everyone else
is less than 2 2 Beta
no
um now we are ready to describe the
algorithm
to initially
to initialize the the data structure
you just start by sample or random Point
r
and return check all of r
if that if like the descent from R to
everyone else is less than beta two beta
you return yes
now
to support relation
what we do
is just
check first
if
X the one that you want to delete is
your
random Point your root uh your r
if that is the case then you just
re-initialize your data structure
otherwise
your random part is still there you do
nothing
and the last thing is to insert
and by the way just to confirm you
should verify that once you delete
something okay once once you handle this
deletion
given that your random point was was
random after this operation
it will still be a random point in your
data set
if you delete the guy the eye you
resemble it if not it's just a guy that
is not like it's still random among the
remaining guy
and to insert a point
what we will do is that
um
just to just to make sure that
this point R remains like a uniformly
random guy what you do is like wisdom
probability which is precisely one Oak
and one other side of your data set
just switch from from like from like
just outside your new new point to be
the r to be r
and then check all
but otherwise
if you don't do this then all you need
to do is just return yes if the new
point x is still close to R within two
to Beta
so you can see that this is the
invariant that we want really
um like is certified but
we really assume obvious adversary here
right
so this is crucial like
because if the adversary is not
oblivious like
um
yeah yeah we need this in the running
time actually yes sorry
let's prove the correctness of algorithm
um
well if the diameter is less than beta
um then they must access some some like
a Center Point
to everyone is less than beta
but then by triangle inequality you have
that this 10 from R to X
is Atmos R we send from R to C star and
from C star to X
sum this together this is less than two
beta
so it means what it means that our
algorithm which is return yes if and
only if the point R have this tense like
less than two beta to everyone else
it will just return Yes in that in this
case
and if we return yes
it means that yeah
it just means that R is is close to
everyone within two beta so the diameter
is less than two beta so the correctness
is uh
it's clear
now for time complexity
um will we use that like the fact that
the point R Is Random
and okay first of all the time to
initialize at the time to check out text
linear uh queries just check the design
from R to everyone
what about a time for deletion
okay
the time for deletion is okay first just
spend one
time to delete
but then okay
you might need to spend like
re-initialize your algorithm which
you'll spend this time to initialize
but this will happen
only if
like you the point of deletion is is
your is your root it's your your random
point
but this
because
um X is independent from R this is where
you exploit the fact that
the input is is like it's oblivious like
um the update is obvious from from r so
this will happen
this probably is just like 1 over X
this is why like you get constant yeah
about the incision time
okay well
um
with some probability right uh you will
assign X tobr
this will happen with probability one
over X
and then you spend time for check out
put this together like
like this is one over X this is X so
it's constant
in other case you just spend one query
you know another case here you just
don't don't like don't read aside X2
don't don't read assign R you just use
the same r
and you just check whether R is this
just check this 10 from R to X
that's just like spend one query
in any case this is like
constant
but not again that this is the place
where
you you need oblivious adversary
Okay so
we get that the expected was just update
time is really constant and
just to conclude this simple algorithm
if you constant update time and
expectations
okay this is simple and but I want to
point out that this is really this
template
that is used by tons of none of like by
non robust algorithm
the template is that
you usually like you spend a lot of time
to build data structure based on some
random point
and you might need to rebuild it but you
will need to rebuild it only when this
random guy is effect affected
but
this random point is stable
stable against an oblivious adversary
because R is random you we don't need to
review often
right because intuitively oblivious
adversary like I is some some random
place but oblivious adversary doesn't
know where R is so it will make it might
affect your data structure here and
there
but it takes long time before like it's
it really affects us
so
so I is unexpected for a long time in
expectation
um that's why like you don't need to
rebuild
your data structure too often
and this is this template has been used
by like many other algorithms like um
maximal meshing spanner
my small Independence said and many many
others yeah
so
foreign
good question so the question is
um because we only returned yes and no
so it seems like
um the adversary
doesn't know where R is
because we just give yes and no answer
um that's a good point however like
there is some place where the adversary
could could learn a bit about r
this is the place where
when okay when with the diameter is
between beta and to Beta
this is the place where again you might
return yes or no
and this answer will reveal some
information about this like the inner
configuration of your data structure it
might not it's not clear how how
effective this revealing is but it will
learn something
okay
if you're in this middle range where I
give out information can you just click
that you can give us
we're all feeling like there's something
here right maybe there's another
category of you know not not oblivious
adversary not you know because it does
seem like right it seems like this is
very low
uh opportunity
is there is there some kind of middle
ground or some kind of characterization
so the question is is that some kind of
uh model of adversary that we can Define
and say that
this algorithm that you just seen still
work against that maybe that adversary
is not completely oblivious
that's a good question and I'm not sure
yeah yeah just just towards that point
correct me if I got this wrong I thought
it's not Universal when people say
adaptive adversary if they mean seeing
the output or they see me in seeing the
internal Randomness yeah and the term is
sometimes used for both cases so
yeah um for this talk it's always the
former just to make sure anybody's talk
I always mean that adaptive fs3 only
sees the output uh but sometimes people
use the the term
non-oblarious to mean that it really say
everything inside uh
when when you think of like
like using data structure
that interact with
um the static algorithm usually the
static algorithm kind of only see your
your answer and it doesn't try to apply
into your internal Randomness that's why
yeah yeah I've been in that situation
quite frequently and the question is
really when do we have a proof against
standard active adversary and when don't
we like I have approximately written
card algorithms uh that are solved the
same flavor and you just it seems really
hard to prove your cartoon and then you
try to resolve to differential privacy
and stuff like that but yeah right
um what is known for this problem
against adaptive adversaries
um so
soda
which shows how to get full
approximation
oh I'm not sure if you will but they
didn't solve a much much like 100
problems like a Care Center
which is just generalization of this one
this is just one Center problem
I'm not sure if you really focus on
diameter can you mesh to approximation
yes
one Center is radius
oh I see yes thank you
it's radius right yeah yeah
the glamor is the same algorithm will
work your modifier
definition of the problem let's go on ah
okay the next template that um is the
yours quite quite like
not as much but very interesting though
um is the to use linear sketch in the
in the data structure and this has been
used in Dynamic algorithm I think for
the first time that is that is best to
my knowledge by uh King cabron and Mao
join
um for worst case Dynamic connectivity
the first algorithm that give worst case
Dynamic connectivity input poly lock
time it use some linear sketch
and um
but
there are some other algorithm too that
usually in a sketch but the point is and
you'll learn more about linear sketch I
think tomorrow for the whole day
um
and the thing is that the sketched
usually inherently assume oblivious
adversary because it used some hash
function
and the random choice of the how you
generate the hash function randomly you
want to hide that random Choice how you
sample the hash function
but anyway like um just want to point
out that like um
trying to get linear sketched against
adaptive adversary is currently actually
one of the
like intensively study topics in in the
streaming community area as well so
it's quite interesting to see whether
like there will be more Synergy and new
development
in this direction
now I want to switch to the robust one
how do people design
um
algorithm for against adaptive adversary
and there are at least
right now I can see three things one is
unique answer
like kind of bituministic almost yeah
another one is the opposite
to be noisy
and there are some other ad hoc way to
do things
so let's start with the first one
so unique answer imply robustness what
do I mean by that I mean that
suppose that you promise that your
algorithm work against oblivious
adversary
but actually uh
if you if the answer of this algorithm
actually is just uniquely the like the
the whole sequence of answer from this
algorithm
is uniquely determine
by the whole sequence of updates
think of deterministic algorithm
it doesn't need to be deterministic if
your answer is just to mean by by the
whole secret from the update sequence
then I claim that this algorithm itself
actually already works against adaptive
adversary
there's nothing deep about this but let
me just uh
uh argue quickly
um so suppose right supports for
contradiction that actually this
algorithm a doesn't work against
adaptive adversary so there is some
adaptive adversary B
that can generate like that can interact
with a
and then generate the update sequence
such that at some point the guarantee of
a fails
against this sequence U
okay
now once you have generated this update
sequence you
let's fix it fix this this sequence
and say that okay now
I'm gonna Define another oblivious
adversary B Prime
this B Prime will just
work with a by fixing this update
sequence U
and feed the update sequence due to to a
one by one
and like this is a fixed sequence now so
this is obvious adversary
and what will happen when when B Prime
feed up this update sequence U
to a
must be have exactly the same way
just because the answer of a is
determined by the update sequence
right so it means that okay because
answer of a is uniquely bit defined by u
a must fail again against against B
Prime
so a actually failed against obvious
adversary and that's contradiction
optimism like here it will be it will be
true with with high probability
um
so if I don't assume some did you
mistake here then like I need this to be
like with high probability
but could you sort of achieve this by by
modifying the problem as an example
looking at the rate like you're looking
at the radius problems the question was
give me an estimate of the radius rather
than given the threshold rather than
giving you the answer if I force my
algorithm to only answers on Powers of I
powers of two within a factor of two
then then it would be that the answers
are determined exactly by
could you modify the problem to make
sure that the answers
uh
very interesting I I'm not sure if I get
your questions that consider the radius
problem right I could frame it as give
me an approximate radius okay but that's
but that by itself like would not fall
under this one but now I can say okay
like I allow you to answer me a power of
three
right once you are a two approximation a
power of three is unique or let's say
power
just to get them strictly right you have
to answer but then it will fall under
this framework and you would get a
determinist like the answers are
uniquely determined by the input and
hence your
with a slight modification you will
actually have an adapter an algorithm
that works against adaptive addresses am
I getting this right yes so the question
okay
the I think the question is like um
can you like is it the case that
um
if you have an algorithm that were
against oblivious adversary
um
and you can just adjust the problem
slightly so that the answer is naturally
unique right then you would get
um
algorithm against adaptive adversary the
answer is yes yeah once you once you
just change the problem definition such
that any correct algorithm must return
unique answer
then you get adaptive again the one
against adaptive adversary it's much
harder because then you have to know
some threshold
yeah yeah so I'm assuming there's an
algorithm that works for like actually
gives you a radius estimate
also there would be a certain radius of
which it has to give a specific answer
if you want to make the answer unique
then there will be certain thresholds
where it has where is clear what it is
we need to know the radius exactly
in order to be able to do a correct
rounding
so you make the problem much harder
that's what I'm saying
I said I just answered sushan home for
this specific problem about radius that
we have seen there will be some like
concern about the where exactly do you
round and that threshold of routing uh
will will be like still might review
some information to MP3 so for this
specific problem it's not that clear but
legitimate answer is fine
okay now like how do people get unique
answers right there are similar way to
to set up algorithm is unique what do
you mean by the updates well the the
classical way and like that many other
many people just do this
um just to make algorithm deterministic
that's the classical way to make
algorithm robust
and um
if the answer is Boolean and it's not
like there is no Gap like like the
radius problem that we have seen like
so if the answer if the answer is
Boolean yes or like yes or no
there is no like a gap where you can
answer anything
then the answer must be unique because
if your algorithm is correct the answer
is uniquely determine
every step
so
every correct algorithm for decision
problem without this Gap
it's just automatically robust
exact answers
and you are robust
and
if you algorithm
as you like the answer is unique or like
a celebrity mistake in a sense like
maybe you want to maintain a spanning
tree
but what you do is you return a minimum
spending tree
and minimize penetrate at least in the
graph that is that has the same weight
is unique so in this case like your
answer is unique from the definition or
you might return the reciprocal
graphically first one
or for any problem
if any then discussed then you are
robust
okay
so that's like um the classical things
to do but let's look at another one
which is new work
it's kind of the opposite one like
instead of being unique there is one
thing now you're being being noisy
the high level idea about this second
approach is just that
when your answer is noisy enough
then the noise actually prevent the
adaptive adversary from learning your
internal configuration
and this is actually formalized and um
um for my life through the connection to
differentiate privacy and adaptive data
analysis
these are the two two areas that we we
have used their Insight from
and
so let me tell you at least
I will
stay at um
like the nice black box transformation
that that works okay
okay
so
please try again later that would be
Jesus say it's like the black box star
information that works for any Dynamic
value problems
um so what do we mean by that I just
mean like the problem where like
for each query you return a single
number
but that that implies a lot of problem
like
distance Dynamic this time Oracle where
like you at each query you you you get
SNT you want to return
um information like the value of STD
stands or the value of estimate card
this is the dynamic value problem or
dynamic Global mean cut what's the size
of global mean cut right now or
approximate size of global mean cut or
approximate diameter and so on okay so
these are our Dynamic value problems
okay
so
I'm gonna tell you what is like the
black box that transform any non-robus
algorithm for dynamic value problems
to the robust one
and
actually
if you don't care much about
about
um
about efficiency
this is easy to achieve
um
because let's say you have some problem
which is dynamic value problem p
and there is some non-robus algorithm
against oblivious adversary
and let's say that it can handle this
algorithm can handle up to T updates
to get a robust algorithm
all you need to do
is just make tea copies of this nanobus
guy
and then
let's say the new algorithm just return
the answer from the Ice copy
on the ice query
okay
so this this now will be robust um
and the reason is just because
the randomness from from AI
okay this random configuration of AI is
leaked at step I
but we know never use it again
so that's fine okay
um
so but like you see that the update time
increase the effect of T where T is the
number of updates
now what is now known is that this can
improve so now let me tell you what is
the Improvement
it's gonna be very similar
okay you have a problem p and you have
an end robust algorithm that works up to
T updates
I'm gonna just make instead of tea
to make Roti
many copies
and what we're gonna do
is just to return
kind of noisy version of the median
of
these copies
and so it's like you just compute
this
query disguise look at the median
actually look at like
approximate median and try to like add
some a bit of noise
um precisely exponentially exponential
exponential nice and that doesn't matter
too much how what exactly is this noise
it's just some noisy version
of median
and one can prove formally that now a
prime is actually robust
I hope to give this full proof in the
next Workshop but
for today I just hope
like for you to see that okay
the noise adding noise actually
it's one generic way to to transform
than robots to robust algorithm
so um
so you see this is like a saving factor
of rho t
so that's that's quite nice and
um by the way like one can reduce the
number of query
um because here like a at each time step
actually we queried C many algorithm
but you can reduce them
the number of query per step from C to
polylog
just by instead of returning private
median of everyone here just sample log
in many guys here and return the private
meeting of of the guided use sample that
will work too
okay
yeah it's quite big but like similar to
what you have so okay this so the
question is like whether square root
here is good enough for application to
get anything useful at all the answer is
yes
um for example
um Mikhail mentioned that he has like he
has like a algorithm for returning
approximate mini cut in root end time
using
this black box together with this idea
you get approximating card algorithm
with update time something like n to the
3 4.
so something here
but it's going to be slower
just to add this is a situation where
nobody would know how to use
the information from input that my
algorithm has so that's why we have to
go through this all this extra cost just
to get approved right yeah yes
is there a lower bound on the number of
Coopers that you need in terms of Q
so
there is a lower bar so the question is
is this tight
yes and the answer is time for this
approach
I'm not sure
um actually
in my like people in
privacy and adaptive data analysis my my
actually
they might not by now but I'm not sure
okay
so these are like the tools generic way
now let me tell you like the like there
are like something to explore and
so
okay
to tell you about this like um let me
give you um simple algorithm for this
problem of edge coloring
the problem is that you have a graph
that undergoes Edge update and let's say
that this graph have small like maximum
degree of Delta
maybe Delta is not too small actually
but it has maximum degree of Delta
and what you want to do is like to
maintain the edge curling
such that any adjacent ish that
um doesn't have the same the same
uh the same color so these two Edge
must they share the word advertex so it
cannot be the same color
and I say I just want to use at most
three data colors
you cannot use less than the other color
for sure but here we use three three
data colors
and the worst case of that time
um is the privilege you can do it in
Delta was cast at that time but we're
gonna do it in constant
in expectation
algorithm going to be quite simple
so
um
first of all let let's set it for each
vertex we maintain a set of color of
edges incident to it
first
and okay we can like um
given s in s update we can update this
set in in just a constant time and
actually we
we're gonna do this too that is given a
color
we want to be able to check whether uh C
is
this color C is in this set in in
constant time as well
to implement this in constant time you
can use array but if you don't care
about consent time you can use binary
search tree and pay log in that that's
not the point here
um okay
now what do we do
when you delete an edge you don't need
to do anything the valid color the valid
coloring is developed
what about insertion
what I'm going to do is just here
yeah yeah I I we keep updating this yeah
right so
but it's going to be constant time yeah
um to to insert
we update this too
but what we're gonna do is
I'm just gonna sample a color to to this
Edge UV
color it from from this
this palette of size three data
you color it
and check if this color is valid that is
like whether this
color is in around you or around you
if it's not then it's free then you use
it if it's not free then use a resample
so the correctness that it maintain that
there's coloring is clear
and how to see the update time well
let's just try to like uh analyze how
much you need to resample how many times
you need to resemble
well
the number of the incision time is just
how many times you resemble because each
time that you resemble you can check
whether the color is free in constant
time
but in expectation the number of
reasonable is just three right
this is just because
the probability that this
color is not free
it's just at most the size of around you
plus the size of the rlv
over your palette size
but
around you and around we have total size
of two layers
three Delta so this is like less than
two to a third
so the number of resampling
it's just a random
wearable that which is a geometry that
followed geometric distribution of
success rate at least
one third
um I'm gonna finish soon yeah
um
so yeah expected insertion time is
constant
so it's a it's a single algorithm
and let's reflect just quickly why is it
actually robust it's randomized but it's
still robust
and this is because you see that
Randomness is purely used to speed up
the
the insertion time it's just used only
to
two like
pick some run color that should be nice
for you
it doesn't like need assumption that
your solution follows some distribution
there's no point of time where you
assume that
um
the thing that you have maintained from
the past follow some distribution no
it can be anything it's just that at
this current time I want to pick
something quickly so that it's
um to speed up at that time
okay I'm always too robustness
um there was new techniques
um called that I call Proactive
resampling
it has been yours in two papers so far
but I hope that it it might be more
useful
um
and the rough idea is that
um the idea is like try we try to work
with adaptive adversary
but we
usually adaptive fs3 can can mess with
you in the sense that it can it can try
to force some bad structure
but what we're going to do is like try
whenever adaptive adversary might create
some bad structure to you you just kind
of resample that part
and make this best structure disappear
um really awake but you can have a look
another thing that is interesting and it
has been used in this new mag flow paper
linear Time map almost linear time back
flow
is that okay they designed the algorithm
that okay
um
the design approximately approximate
means mean ratio cycle dynamic question
but instead of this sign the one that
have good approximation
they just want to design the one that is
competitive against
stable solution sequence instead of
optimal solution sequence
so kind of daily lacks that
approximation guarantee
and then compete with object like don't
try to be optimal at our time but just
by try to be competitive to the
something that they call stable
um
and once you do that you like
you you can maintain something that's
still nice and like maybe not optimal
but nice enough for the for the
application
um
in any case
um I think we really need more theory on
how this design
robust algorithms and I think it's like
interesting when you know to explore
um yeah thanks a lot for today
thank you
thank you questions
[Music]
so thanks that's all very nice survey so
just you actually use proactive
resampling in the radius one right like
we were resampling whenever a new Point
came in with some small probability 1
over X
uh you might think of it like that
um
I don't actually I'm not sure how to
make that algorithm really worse against
adaptive adversary formally but here
when I say I use proactive resampling
it's really against adaptive adversary
if I followed correctly I guess in the
diameter thing we're resampling when it
really broke and in that paper you're
sampling where it's not broken yet but
like it might break later
even it was not broken
but I know it it would not work
I think you had a sampling even when it
was not broken right I see
four questions
I thought you had something in debt
about
inverse maintenance which is some noisy
thing yes
so it falls under that
um yeah it is like um so there are two
papers that use uh noise right now
um and um
wait
this one is the Black Box statement that
I State this one
and others
um they add noise too
um but like I didn't
talk about it so if I may yes there are
a bunch of different I think strategies
for for adding noise I think this use of
differential privacy with a collection
of them is one very nice one
um the inverse maintenance paper you do
a trick where you estimate something so
precisely that if you like add a little
bit of a nice distribution the resulting
distribution is like close to what the
distribution would have been if you had
exactly computed and add noise and
they're like not distinguishable so it's
still in the broad family of AD noise
but maybe a different way of reasoning
about the fact or the kind of
indistinguishability formatting that
advice is that yeah yeah
um I can I I can talk offline about more
ways of hiding Randomness and
optimization with it but uh more
questions
all right well thank you again
[Applause]
tomorrow until 3 30 and
there's the upstairs he's upstairs okay
thank you